(jazzy music)
- I don't know what I was thinking.
So I'm a big fan of Casey Neistat,
and I've been following his vlog
since 2015 when it started.
And at that time in my life, I thought it was too late
to pursue any kind of creative career.
But after watching him and listening to his story,
I realized that it wasn't too late.
I spent all my time online learning how to make videos,
and it eventually led me here to New York City.
I'm really curious what a day in the life
of Casey Neistat looks like,
so I'm gonna try to run like Casey,
every day, for the next five days.
Before I can run like Casey,
I need to figure out how far he actually runs.
- About 10 miles per day.
We watched over 200 of the original vlogs
and he mentions running in 37 of them,
and out of those 37 he ran 369 miles,
and if you divide that up, it's about 10 miles per day.
- About to take the first couple steps on day one here.
(rap music)
Calves are really starting to tighten up.
Yeah, this is tough, this is really tough.
Alright seven miles in,
kinda reaching that limit, three more.
Just passed the eight mile mark, everything
in my body's telling me to stop, two more to go.
10 miles done.
Oh my god, I'm tired.
I can already feel my legs starting to like,
we will see how I feel in the morning.
So far so good.
Alright so it's day two and I am already so impressed
with Casey, I don't know how he does this every single day.
Alright one mile done, today feels rough so far.
Casey definitely runs down this pier.
Seven more to go.
Look at that, this is such a good spot too.
(upbeat music)
I don't know how you do this everyday.
Put your phone down, run, come back.
I mean that really adds some distance after a while.
I wasted a lot of time filming stuff.
I have to run the next five miles in under an hour
to get back to work in time for a shoot,
so I gotta just keep going.
I'll check back in at the end.
Another 10 miles done.
The last two were a real, real struggle.
Okay, on to day three.
My hood--
Alright, to be totally honest, this part gets boring,
I'm running, I'm tired, I'm sore, alright we get it,
so let's just jump ahead to day four,
but the end of day four, and we'll go from there.
That was the worst run yet.
I mean, everything is just (bleep) soaked.
So if you're a fan of the old vlogs,
you know that Casey would run in the city
quite a bit but he'd also run somewhere else.
So if I'm gonna run like Casey, I gotta really go for it.
(rock music)
Alright, a few hours later, I am out of the city
in New London, Connecticut
for my final day of running, let's do it.
Alright, beach was super fun,
I'm gonna head to the town now.
I'm so close to finishing, oh my god.
The week's really catching up to me today.
Almost there.
I feel a lot slower running here, 'cause you can see so far.
In the city I'm just flying past people
and buildings, it feels so quick.
I'm not very fast I guess.
Oh my god, I did it.
(bleep)
That was stupid, I don't wanna ever do this again.
10 miles, every day for five days is done.
I need something to eat.
Well it's done.
I ran 10 miles a day for five days.
I am exhausted, my whole body is so sore.
I respect the guy even more, to run 10 miles,
and film it, and vlog your life.
I don't know how he balances it all, I really don't.
I gotta work harder.
Ah, (bleep)